everybody was up I know you've been
freaking out about maybe you know
spider-man maybe leaving the Marvel
Universe so I'm going to explain what's
going on it's not as bad as it sounds if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Marvel
and DC videos every week usually things
are not as dire as they seem from the
title of this video here so spider-man
might be leaving the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
after he finishes the second spider-man
Home Coming movie so the premise the
idea just makes it sound absolutely
terrible but the reason that everyone's
reporting this is because Amy Pascal who
used to be the head of Sony o studio arm
just gave an interview where she talked
about how wonderful it was that they
were able to get all three Studios
Disney Marvel and Sony to sign on the
dotted line to share this character and
make some really amazing movies she was
like it might not ever happen again
I'll read her full statement in the
minute but she implied that after they
get done making all the Marvel based
spider-man movies with Tom Hall and that
includes the Spider Man solo films as
well as the infinity war crossovers and
any other crossovers they might do that
that might be the end of their sharing
arrangement with the character so
everybody was freaking out no more
spider-man in the MCU how dare you so
here's the full statement this is what
she said one of the things I think that
is so amazing about this experience is
that you don't have studios deciding to
work together to make a film very often
in fact it may never happen again
after we do the sequel talking about
spider-man homecoming 2 all explained
that movie in a second but then she goes
on to say because Sony Disney and Marvel
all decided that the right thing to do
was to allow Peter Parker in spider-man
to be in the MCU and to work with the
Marvel guys and have them produce this
film she talking about spider-man
homecoming and then she goes on to say I
think that it was a very rare thing for
three companies to do a very brilliant
thing for them to decide to do because
there are only so many stories that you
could tell again and again and again
about Spidey she's talking about the
origin story so it was a very selfless
very smart thing on the part of all the
companies so she was just really happy
that all these companies came together
but just to explain the spider-man
homecoming sequel
they've already dated that for 2019
there's another film that year Avengers
infinity war so worst case scenario even
if he does leave the MCU after that
second spider-man movie
he would probably also show up during
the next infinity war movie when she was
talking about not being able to do the
same story over and over again just some
context this is a funny story if you
wonder why when they did Amazing
Spiderman they had to retell the origin
story it's part of the terms of sony's
use of the characters they have to tell
a version of the origin story when they
tell a new franchise and because the
Andrew Garfield movies were meant to be
a new franchise they had to retell it so
if they were to do a Tom Holland movie
that was not with Marvel they would have
had to do another origin story all over
again people would have been so pissed
so when she's saying that they wouldn't
been able to do it the way they did it
for spider-man homecoming it just means
that because they had the sharing
arrangement with Marvel they were able
to tell a different kind of story and
just make something that people hadn't
seen before it was way more fun
so the important takeaway from this
everyone's like does that mean that
Spidey is leaving the MCU is that that's
not what she's saying she's just saying
that they might not be able to make
another arrangement it's going to be
really hard because this is going to
make a boatload of money and what's
happening is is that because of the
sharing arrangement Marvel doesn't see a
dime from the movie profits they make
money off of the toys off of the
merchandising from the spider-man
character they get creative control of
the character they get to say how he's
used what the script is what's going on
Sony gets some input into that but what
people are thinking is is it because
Sony will probably make a boatload of
money off their spider-man movies
they're trying to create their own
spider-man Cinematic Universe with this
venom movie the black cat silver sable
movie so what could possibly happen is
is that they build those up so that they
have their own version of the MCU and
they don't need the marketing help or
the creative help of Marvel anymore and
they don't want to share the character
but because I think that would be
disastrous on everyone's part people are
loving this because he's a shared
character he gets to be part of the MCU
so of course it all comes down to money
Sony wants more money they want more
control of the character Marvel is just
going to have to find a way to deal with
that when they come to the table again
after the second spider-man Home Coming
felt and they'll have those negotiations
way far in advance of that they're not
going to wait till 2019 when the movie
comes out to renegotiate the contract so
odds are what will happen is is that
Sony will get more
our control of the character more saying
how he's used and he will show up a
little bit less during Marvel movies but
he'll still be a shared character you'll
still see him in big team ups but
they'll just save him for the very very
special occasion do not expect to see
spider-man during ant-man and the wasp
but there's always the chance that he
could show up during a Captain America
movie whatever ends up happening with
that character of Chris Evans resigned
to his contract there's still so many
different things that could happen that
it's pointless to worry about it now all
it is is a money issue they just need to
renegotiate the terms Sony will get a
little more control a little bigger part
of the merchandising PI because that's
where the majority of the profits come
from and they'll be happy so they'll
just continue to share the character so
let me know in the comments do you
actually think that Sony would be stupid
enough to not renew their contract with
Marvel and risk having the exact same
thing happen this happened with the
spider-man character in the last 10
years the leverage that they would
arguably have liked this spider-man
Cinematic Universe doesn't exist yet the
venom movie has to do really well the
other movies they do like black cats
silver sable that doesn't sound like a
really big movie right now I mean it
could be we never know like we haven't
seen it yet but they just have this big
house of cars that they're building
their spider-man bed on so what will
probably happen is is that those
spin-off movies will do okay but not so
well that they can say yeah we don't
need to share you with Marvel we don't
need the army of Marvel's fans or
Margo's creative support we can do it
all by ourselves I think it just
wouldn't terribly for everybody involved
it would be a complete deserves to the
character in Tom Holland might stop
being spider-man if that happened they
might have to recast the actor meaning
that they would have to tell another
version of the origin story again for
the terms of their use of the character
so it's just a big bag of fail don't
worry about it it's just a premise is
what was freaking people out because you
hear somebody as powerful as Amy Pascal
saying that you're like wait a minute
you were definitely in the room when
they were hammering out this deal so
it's kind of scary but she's not the
head of Sony anymore she resigned with a
little bit of dignity when they had that
big hacking scandal so Sony almost went
up in flames a couple of years ago
because they got hacked all this data
got released their films were doing
really poorly so she was the head of the
studio at the time she left somebody
else came in but because she had been
producing the spider-man
films up to that point she started
co-producing with Kevin Feige when they
started their arrangement so she's still
working on spider-man stuff but she's
not like a big decision maker at Sony
anymore so what will happen is in better
news more fun things to talk about I'll
do another spider-man video later this
week for the movie leave all your video
requests in the comments below the more
requests you guys leave me the better
our discussions are congratulations to
the latest spider-man giveaway winner
platinum x2a you win those action
figures please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video so I'll
announce the winner the next time I post
a Marvel video so while you wait for
that you can click here to rewatch that
spider-man trailer and you can click
here for brand new flash thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video